A truck plowed through a crowd celebrating Bastille Day in Nice, France.
At least 80 have been reported killed in the incident,...
...which is being treated as a terrorist attack.
French media report an ID found in the truck suggests the 31-year-old driver...
...had dual French-Tunisian citizenship.
Police killed the driver of the truck,...
...and are, at the moment, investigating if he had accomplices.
Witnesses say the truck driver was firing a gun as he zigzagged through the crowd,...
...and authorities say the truck was loaded with grenades.
Police have advised residents of Nice to remain in their homes.
French President Francois Hollande spoke in a televised address early Friday, saying,...
..."France has been struck on the day of her national holiday,...
...the symbol of liberty."
He will hold an emergency security and defense meeting Friday.
World leaders have condemned the attack.